-Welcome back.
So we have two panels
this afternoon--
one on public discourse
and this one on big data.
So I'll ask the
panelists to come up.
And I'm going to introduce the
moderator, Rebecca Lemov, who
is a professor in the Department
of the History of Science,
and she's also the author of a
book called Database of Dreams,
which is about using early
database technology to try
to construct a large database
of social, psychological,
anthropological data,
and is currently
working on history of course of
interrogation and brainwashing,
which sounds fascinating.
So I'll turn it over to Rebecca.
-Thank you for the
introduction, and thanks
for the chance to be here.
I really enjoyed the day so
far, and I think our panel now
will offer a shift
in perspective
and also a shift in methodology.
So I'll try to frame that.
Let's see.
So we live in what is sometimes
called the petabyte era,
and this pronouncement
in turn causes
much discussion of
the sheer size of data
that is being produced
as well as the rapidity
with which that's happening.
And I'm going to make
this statistic up,
but you hear things
like more data
is being created in
the last 10 years
than in all of human
history combined-- or maybe
in the last 10 minutes.
We're not quite sure.
But certainly it's mounting up.
And what is often forgotten, I
think, or temporarily put aside
in such excited and
excitable discussions
is how much of this
newly created stuff
is made of and out of
personal data, the almost
literal mining, tracking, and
harvesting of subjectivity
of people's lives,
in other words.
And I think that point was
made earlier by Janet Mock
in the keynote discussion,
where she said, "Our phones are
extensions of ourselves.
We carry ourselves on them."
And so this panel,
in a sense, looks
at what happens when that
data circulates and is
amassed in large amounts
or studied in other ways,
and what we can
learn when it becomes
the topic of social science.
And so when introducing
the topic of big data,
I often start with the 1973
Charlton Heston classic Soylent
Green, which is set in the
sci-fi dystopian future of 2022
in case any of you
haven't seen it recently,
in which pollution,
overpopulation, depleted
resources, dying oceans, and
assisted suicide are the norm,
and the rations are this
stuff called soylent green.
And, of course, the
famous tag line--
I hope I'm not ruining
it for anyone--
is that soylent green
turns out to be people.
But you could also argue
that big data is people
in a, perhaps, suggestive way.
And today in the press,
in the business world
and scholarly
journals, the question
arises of what is
unique about big data?
Is it hype?
Will the phrase even
exist in 5 years?
Often definitions of big
data are strangely circular,
as in this one from the
Columbia Journalism Review--
"Big data is a
catchall label that
describes a new way of
understanding the world," which
basically boils down to big
data is data that is very big.
I teach a whole
class on the history
and present and
future of big data,
so ambiguity and the
hype of it, actually,
is quite useful for
discussing a range of topics
about basically how technology
is changing our lives,
and in that spirit
that's one of the reasons
we have titled this
panel Big Data.
Many resort to
definitions of big data
that stress the three V's
which are volume, variety,
and veracity.
And these, in fact, were
coined in 2001 by an industry
analyst who was
trying to describe
the problems with big
data, not necessarily
its revolutionary
properties, but they've
gone on to become the very
definition of big data.
Others talk about its
transformational properties,
and in a bold piece
for Wired magazine,
the technology evangelist
Chris Anderson claimed
the end of theory
had been reached
and that so much data now exists
that it's unnecessary to build
a hypothesis to
test scientifically,
but rather the data can,
if you properly handle it,
speak for itself.
And so I think we have
a couple data scientists
and an ethnographer of
identity in social media today
who will speak to some
of these questions.
But I thought I would
start by just reminding us
that some of these
qualities of big data
that are important
to keep in mind
are precisely
where it comes from
and its quality of being
generated continuously.
So if you think about things
like the continuous recording
of retail purchases,
digital devices that
record the history
of their own use,
like mobile phones or
the logging of banking
or clickstream data,
recording people's
navigations through websites
or apps, or the way that we do
leave a stream in our online
interactions of comments,
of likes and clicks.
For example, in 2012
Walmart was generating
more than 2.5 petabytes
of data relating
to more than 1 million customer
transactions every hour.
And Facebook reported
a couple years ago
that it was processing 2.5
billion pieces of content,
including language
links, comments,
and likes-- which
have now proliferated
into those other
little icons-- per day.
And people upload 300
million photos per day.
So today we have a chance to
listen to three researchers who
are, in a sense, in the
trenches with this massive
proliferation, and
trying to figure out
what it means for
gender, in particular.
The three people
we're going to hear,
I think it is fair
to say, have not
taken for granted the personal
and gender implications
of these new sources of data.
And I should add each
is unique in how exactly
they approach their subject,
but what they have in common is
a deep concern with using
the unique properties
of these burgeoning
data sources to study
language's formative
role in gender identity--
both its maintenance
and reinforcement,
and its deconstruction.
So we'll see how
gender identity can
be both reinforced and
perhaps maintained, and also
deconstructed.
And so our first
participant is Ben Hookway.
He is the CEO of
Relative Insight,
which is a UK-based
marketing analysis firm.
There are longer
bios in your program.
He has a really
interesting background,
which I just thought I would
mention, in law enforcement,
pioneering the use
of language analysis
to identify sexual predators.
And more recently, his firm
is moving towards marketing.
He also has a background
in several technology-based
businesses such as Vidiactive,
Next Device, Critical Path
in the UK and the USA.
So I'm looking forward to
hearing about his work.
-So normally I present this
to venture capital firms
and big brands and
marketers and agencies
and so on, so it's
probably fair to say
you're not my normal crowd.
But I'm just going to tell you
what we do, where we came from,
and since we're
all about data, I'm
going to show you
some data, as well.
So I-- the language in
America are dear to my heart.
I did actually used
to live in the-- I'm
from Scotland originally.
And I moved to the
States when I was 24,
and at my first ever dinner
party, one of the guests
asked me at what age do
you start getting taught
English in Scottish schools?
So I said, well,
8, but I've only
just become fluent which is
why I still have an accent.
The accent's been
kicked out of me
somewhere after staying
6 years in the states
and doing various things
and then go back to the UK.
So now I'm CEO of
Relative Insight,
and Relative Insight is an
advanced language analytics
business.
And essentially what we do
is specialize in comparing
sets of language.
So we do two things-- we
turn this subjective thing,
this unstructured thing called
language-- which people tend
to be quite emotive about
and have high expectations
of-- into data.
But then the second
critical thing we do
is that we compare
sets of data, and we
specialize in looking at
the differences between sets
of language.
And this is important
because it's
the differences which
tend to be important,
not the language itself.
So we're actually
originally a collaboration
between government agencies
in the UK and academia,
and we were developed
to catch bad people.
And one of the examples
of catching bad people
is online child protection.
So in an open chat
forum, we can tell
if you're a 12-year-old
girl or if you're
a 30-year-old man doing a
very sophisticated impression
of a 12-year-old girl.
Now, the way we do that is by
taking known 12-year-old girl
language, taking suspected
language, comparing them.
And the two sets might
be 99% identical,
but that's not what
you're interested in.
What you're interested
in is the 1% difference
that's significant.
And unfortunately, if an
offender's undertaken that kind
behavior, very often they'll
have more than one persona
in a chat room, so they
manipulate conversation
by pretending to
be multiple people
and trying to direct
behavior and so on.
And we can detect when
that's happening, as well.
So we do all that good
stuff, but we make our money,
actually, by using this
technology in brands.
So we help brands
sell you all stuff
because you will respond
better to messages if it's
in your own vernacular, and
in the style of language
that you tend to use.
The trick, though,
is how to find out
what that language
style is if you don't
know what you're looking for.
And so by comparing
two given sets of data,
understanding the
critical differences,
then you can hone in on
how different people speak.
So it's worth talking about.
Earlier on in the sessions
this morning there
was some discussion about
channels of communication,
and Twitter was
brought up a lot.
So we do analyze Twitter,
and we do analyze
Facebook language a lot.
However, we also
spend a lot of time
analyzing forums
and review sites.
So when you're looking at
language as a data source,
you've got to consider
the source of the data.
And what we find is social,
and Twitter, especially--
although it's easy to
get because it's API
accessible and so on--
it's very, very volatile,
and it's not necessarily a
very good medium or long-term
reflection of what's really
going on in the world.
Forums, by contrast, tend to be
a lot more thoughtful, there's
more room to write, people
aren't reacting or re-Tweeting
anything.
They're giving a
considered opinion,
so we spend quite a
lot of time on there.
And we even do things like
call center transcripts,
we do employee opinion surveys.
So rather than having
to tick boxes 1 to 5,
are you highly satisfied
or dissatisfied?
You can actually write
free-form comments
and this can get analyzed
and tracked over time,
and so on and so on.
So when we talk about
language, what do we mean?
Well, we mean two things,
really-- the topics people
talk about, but also style.
So are they emotive?
Are they particularly
expressive?
Are they factual?
Are there particular
language markers
that they tend to use that
if you're not in that group
you wouldn't know?
So for example, in the UK,
one of the big mother's forums
is called Mumsnet.
And so if you did
some analysis on that
and you look at
the language, you
see things like DD, DS,
DH coming up all the time.
And you just kind of
ignore these normally,
but only by comparing
language sets and seeing
these things appear as
something significant
do you realize they're
probably pretty important.
It turns out they stand for
darling husband, darling son,
darling daughter,
and so on and so on.
And this represents the cultural
code of that group of people.
So if you're trying to
engage with these people
and you don't talk like them,
you're instantly exposed.
A really good
example of this was
we work with Microsoft
Mobile, as well,
and they launched a phone
which had a great camera in it.
Part of the ad campaign
was to DSLR enthusiasts,
proper photographers.
So use this phone and
take amazing pictures,
was kind of the slogan.
But if you do a comparison
between DSLR enthusiasts talk
and how smartphone
review people talk,
you find, actually, that DSLR
people don't take pictures.
What they do is shoot images.
And if you don't
know this, you end up
with this what we call
Dad at the disco effect.
So most people have probably
experienced-- and I'm a Dad
and I've done disco dancing--
that technically they're
doing all the right things,
but it's just not cool, right?
For this kind of unknown reason.
And language has
the same effect.
So that's the kind
of stuff we do.
This is just who we
sell our stuff to.
So once you get it in
your head that language
is nothing but data and the
best results come from comparing
sets of data, you
can compare language
across lots of really
interesting axes.
So two groups of
mothers forums in the UK
talk about the same topic
in very different ways.
People will type and express
themselves differently
on an iPhone from an
iPad from a desktop.
Tracking language over time
is fascinating-- everything
from how they're
talking about your brand
before the ad campaign compared
with after the ad campaign.
The delta tells you the real
effect of the ad campaign,
not what the ad agency tells you
the effect of the ad campaign
is.
But equally, forums have
been around so long now
that you can go back in time
and look at societal change.
So we've done
projects, for example,
on attitudes to facial
cosmetic surgery have
changed over the last 8 years.
And you can tell this by
looking at the language
and tracking it.
Obviously different people
in different locations,
how different brands
speak to each other,
and so on and so on.
But increasingly we're moving
into the world of beyond
conventional demographics.
This is the other key thing
we're doing at the moment.
So demographics are
a traditional way
for marketing people
to use a proxy
to identify an individual.
And they're really out of date.
I'm 43 and I live in
Manchester in England,
and I've got a house, and
I've got a car, and so what?
People hold multiple personas.
I hold multiple personas
during the day, in the morning,
in the evening,
when I'm working,
when I'm doing presentations,
and so on and so on.
And so what we do is model
people with a commonality--
either they're all
a member of a forum,
or everyone who follows
a particular music artist
on Twitter. .
You can grab these, all this
language together, and pull it
together and that's a much
better way of targeting people.
So that's what we do.
And I get to talk about
politics because I'm just
a bemused observer of
your political process
at the moment.
Although I was in the states
when Bush Jr. got elected,
so I've sort of
lived through it,
but I do have the right, I
feel, because I live in the UK
to mock you.
So we're going to
have a little quiz.
What I'm showing you
here is candidate A,
and this is candidate
A's Twitter stream,
and this is how they tend
to talk on Twitter compared
with another candidate.
So this is what
this candidate tends
to over index on
compared to candidate B.
So they tend to use social media
mentions a lot, personal names,
so they name people
in their Tweets,
evaluation-- good,
judgment of appearance--
beautiful, so that's beautiful,
awesome, gorgeous, and so on
and so on.
They're degree boosters, so
they're quite expressive,
and so on and so on.
This doesn't mean the
other candidate doesn't
use these attributes,
it just means
that this candidate uses them
consistently and statistically
significantly more.
This is candidate A
compared to candidate C.
And the green dots are
basically the same attributes
which keep on appearing.
So the point being
it doesn't matter
who you compare
this candidate with,
they have these
significant attributes.
Who wants to guess
who candidate A is?
It is Trump.
And if you were a marketer
and you were looking at this,
you'd say this is great--
personal names, positive.
You don't know anything
else about their persona,
but linguistically
this is a good brand.
Candidate D-- same thing.
What candidate D says more
than candidate E. Sorry,
just one more thing-- this
is Trump against Sanders.
That's Trump against Clinton.
This is what candidate
D says-- same principle.
And again, same
themes keep coming up.
So this particular
candidate continually
keeps over indexing on certain
things, having to do stuff,
discussing conflict,
mentioning family, health care,
gun control, and
so on and so on.
So guess who this is.
That's Clinton.
The point is Hillary Clinton
sounds like Hillary Clinton
no matter who you compare it to.
You can compare it
to Carly Fiorina,
and there's no real difference
between comparing her
to Carly Fiorina or comparing
her to Donald Trump.
She's continually over
indexing on these things.
Point being, from a pure
linguistic, blind point of view
in the presidential race,
gender has got no effect
at all on the language.
So any time gender
comes up, it's
because of other
societal aspects.
There we go.
That was all I was going to say.
I'm sure we'll get
questions about that later,
but there we go.
-Thanks, that was wonderful.
Our next speaker
is Lyle Ungar who's
a professor and the Graduate
Group Chair of Computer
and Information Science at
University of Pennsylvania.
He also teaches in the
Psychology Department.
And he teaches an
array of courses
from cognitive science to
artificial intelligence
to machine learning and
data mining, crowdsourcing,
management of
technology, and he was
mentioning developing a course
on the singularity, which
sounds enticing.
-So we heard incredibly
powerful personal narratives
this morning.
This afternoon we're
talking about what
we can see in aggregate
looking at language.
I work with a group
of psychologists
and computer scientists called
the World Well-being Project,
trying to measure
well-being of people
through the language they use.
The theory is that measuring
stuff helps to drive change.
If you measure GDP,
one focuses on GDP.
If we can measure
well-being-- whatever that is,
that's a hard question--
we can try and define it.
So people ask a lot of
questions, mostly very
ill-formed-- do women
talk more than men?
But we try, in psychology, to
take these sloppy questions--
what does it mean to be nicer
or be less assertive-- make them
precise, measure them, and
get away from abstract debates
to concrete measurement.
One concrete
example-- not my work,
but before we get there--
Matthias Mehl measured
a bunch of men and women,
put little audio recorders
on their lapels,
counted the words.
Who uses more
words, men or women?
Well, the top two, three
talkers in this group were men,
the least talkers
were mostly men, too.
On average, there's
not a huge difference.
OK, one can go back
and do similar studies
in the office place.
It is true by and large--
men interrupt women
a lot more than
women interrupt men,
although it's a lot different
for senior female managers,
at least in the tech industry
where it's been measured.
A lot of these things can
be measured and quantified.
Are you being interrupted?
Yeah, if you're female, you are.
We don't need to
speculate anymore.
Cool.
So I'm interested not just
in these quantitative big
pictures.
I want to look at the words that
people use and understand them,
and the wonderful
thing for me is
that people used to sit
around the campfire talking
and I couldn't measure it
because I'm a measurement guy,
but now they're all Tweeting
and posting to Facebook
and sharing it
with me, and I can
monitor all their private or
semi-private conversations.
So what I want to do today is to
talk about language and gender,
and then language,
gender, and personality.
Let's see what we can measure.
Now, luckily for
me, 70,000 people
agreed, each individually,
to share their Facebook posts
with me.
They said yes, you may
download all the Facebook
posts I've made.
This is opt in, not stealing.
They declared their gender
as male or female-- sorry,
this is 2 or 3 years old.
This is before the new
modern Facebook more choices,
so everyone in this
group has either
declared male or female--
very old fashioned, I know.
We have their age to
control for statistically,
and they took a very
standard personality test.
I'll say in a second
what the personality
things are, but things like
extroversion, introversion.
Cool.
So we can look at
what words differ.
Now, before I show you
these horrible stereotypes,
which are just reality--
you can like them or not.
They're like Trump--
they're there.
I can't help it,
but I can at least
measure it and look at it.
What I'm going to
show you is the words
that most differ
between men and women.
On average, words like the, a,
it are used roughly equally,
but there are words that differ.
So let's see how
these words differ.
One of the words most
indicative of being
female-- oh, it's embarrassing.
First of all, note for a
word-- "love you" is a word,
"so happy," "so" with four
O's, five O's-- very typical
of females.
The old guys out there, you know
that little less than 3 means?
Yeah, you do.
You're not an old guy.
A heart, OK?
And you see things like
"boyfriend," and "I miss"--
very cliche, sorry.
What does it look
like to be male?
Words most predictive of
being male-- I'm a little bit
embarrassed, since
I'm obviously male.
Let me say it's not all bad.
Males do talk more about
engineering and politics,
and interestingly, subtle
things-- males talk more
about "my wife," whereas
females-- and these are,
again, averaged over everyone,
so this is predominantly
heterosexual-- females
talk more about "husband,"
they talk about husband and
other people's husbands, too.
They're a little more inclusive
in their discussion there.
Cool.
So I'm going to show
you a bunch of these.
What I've done is
cluster together
sets of words that tend to
co-occur, which is often
a little more interpretable.
So here's the same set of female
words, but you can see topics.
And I'll call them topics--
their fancy technical term
is Latent Dirichlet Allocation,
but don't worry about it.
It's words that
show up together--
"happy birthday," "boyfriends,"
"cute baby," "adorable."
And similarly for
males, I can look
at the topics that
show up, Again, I
want to point out that
males do on average talk
more about government
than females.
So this is what people are
distinctively talking about.
How accurate is this?
We can tell you the computer
and, given someone's
Facebook posts and the
words that they use
and their self-declared
gender, were 92% accurate.
We can also show these same
Facebook posts or Tweets
to human raters and say,
is this a man or a woman?
What do you think it is?
Humans are pretty good at
looking at a Facebook post
and say, that's a
girl, that's a boy,
but they make some mistakes.
One of the many
definitions of stereotype
is some mistaken view.
I can look at the
words that most
correlate with incorrect
labels of people.
So people who are judged
to be women but are men
are using words like "my" and
"love" and "hair" and "baby"
and "happy."
People who are, in fact,
women but judged as men
use words like "Ebola,"
"research history,"
and "state."
So what's happening?
Interestingly, the human
raters are picking up
on correct statistical
trends in the sense
that women do talk more
about love than men,
and men do talk more about
research and state than women,
but they're overweighting them.
They see someone talking about
sports or about politics, they
go, crap, must be a guy.
Wrong.
It gives some
statistical indication
that it might be a guy, but it
doesn't mean it must be a guy.
So it's interesting to watch
these systematic errors
that people make.
I want to shift gears now
and talk about personality.
We have 70,000 people,
these same people who
shared their Facebook posts
and took a standard five-factor
model, big five
personality measurement,
and we can then look at the
words that correlate with each
of these five factors.
I'm going to talk
about two of them
today, starting
with extroversion.
What do extroverts talk about?
And these are controlled
for age and sex,
so this is as
balanced as I can get.
And it's pretty good.
It's "party," and I
love the "cant wait."
These guys are in
such a hurry, they
can't even put the apostrophes
into with "cant," right?
This is amazing.
This is fun.
I wish I were an extrovert, but
most academics who do science
tend to be a little more
on the introvert side.
What do introverts, my
colleagues, look like?
Apart from the angst, there's
words like "apparently," which
are words of more
cognitive complexity,
there's more "reading"
and "drawing,"
more books, more
zombies-- I'm not sure.
OK, so that's
introversion, extroversion.
We're also going to talk
today about agreeableness.
Agreeable Americans-- these
are all American sampless--
talk a lot about religion,
actually-- awesome.
Disagreeable people-- OK, sorry.
I should have given
a warning, but I
assume everyone here is adult
and able to deal with these.
So rather different
words of agreeableness,
disagreeableness,
introversion, extroversion.
We have these for
a bunch of these.
We can predict your
personality about
as accurately as your
Facebook friends can.
So it's not great, but it's
a fair amount of signal.
But we know for each
person whether they
say they were a man or
a woman, and again I
apologize for the
people who don't
want to pick either
of those categories,
but this is again old Facebook.
This is 2 and 1/2 years old.
So what are we going to do?
We're going to look at a classic
circumplex-- fancy word again--
looking to characterize people
on degrees of how assertive
they are, how
dominant or assertive,
versus how submissive,
the vertical axis,
and something that's called
affiliation, connection,
agreeable-- it's not quite
the same as agreeableness,
but how much they tie to
other people versus don't.
So we're going to put people
onto this piece there,
and people sometimes do
intermediate versions
of combinations of
these to say where they
fit in the personality scale.
But the important
thing for us is
that we can do this
vertical dominance,
and this horizontal
affiliation maps roughly
onto the agreeableness
extroversion,
with a slight rotation,
that I showed you before.
So these are correlated
but not the same,
so extroverts tend to be
dominant and a little bit warm.
Introverts tend to
be the opposite.
So we can look from
our personality
and say something about-- I
don't know if women are nice
or not, but I can see if they're
warmer and more agreeable
by their language.
So we can map lots of topics.
We have 2,000 Facebook topics.
We can code them with how male
in blue or female in yellow
they are, where they
fit in this piece there,
we can look at all the words,
which we don't have time
to look through, but I want to
show you two dimensions of this
in some detail.
So along the bottom axis,
which is a little hard to read,
is male to female.
On the vertical axis is hostile
to warm, to grieve affiliation.
And every dot is a word topic.
I've shown a few of those.
I hope they can be seen.
So you can see, for
example, in the bottom left,
all those swearing
are hostile males.
Up in the right, "shopping,"
"Christmas," "grocery"
are warm females, but
"shopping" is not particularly
an affiliative binding thing.
Up top, "family," "friends,"
"wonderful," "blessed,"
"amazing"-- strong
affiliation, strong female.
And we can see in
general, women do talk--
and I think they actually
believe-- with more connection
on average.
And again I have to emphasize
everyone is different.
It's like talking
more or talking less,
this is averaged
over 70,000 people.
But in terms of characterizing
a broader American population,
you can see that
women on average
do seem much more connective.
Makes sense?
The other dimension--
and this is not
a surprise in psychology--
that's been disputed more
is assertiveness,
the positive version.
Dominance may be less positive.
Where do men and women sit
in terms of how much they
tend to be assertive or not?
And there the connection
is much weaker.
What we find again in the
bottom-- males on the left,
females on the right.
And assertiveness, it's
statistically significant,
but not very big-- actually,
we find women slightly more
assertive than men.
Now again, one has to
say this is on Facebook.
May be different in the office.
I'd love to have
lots of recordings
of office conversations.
Some of the companies
I talk to are
starting to do this and
analyze those discussions.
But you can see, again, these
sort of systematic differences
where very male and
very non-assertive
is "computers,"
"programming," "Photoshop."
Very male and very assertive
is, again, swearing.
But sort of in the middle, this
"happy birthday," "wishing,"
"sister"-- quite
general neutral.
So we don't have time
to look at all of these.
If you go to
WWBP.org, our website,
you can go and play with these
and look at different versions.
It's all up there to play with.
But lots of insight to mull
over what our people are talking
and how are they
talking about it?
So what have we seen?
Well, first of all, there
is systematic differences
between males and
females and how
they post on Facebook-- not
surprising-- and systematic
errors that people
make in overweighting,
for example, how likely
someone discussing sports
is to be male.
We've seen that words
show personality.
The marketers love that, but
I love that also in the sense
that I want to go and
customize hospital treatments.
If you're more conscientious
or less conscientious,
you should probably be getting
different instructions,
do things there.
We've seen that assertiveness
is often misjudged.
I haven't given you
the literature on this,
but a lot of controversy.
But I think there's often a fair
amount of assertiveness going
by women, and if
you can quantify it,
you get a better idea of what's
happening or not happening.
More broadly, I'm in the
business of building tools--
tools for measuring things.
And I'm the business
of selling--
I don't do it for money, give
away for free, all open source.
I'm in the business of
selling these tools to help
other researchers do them.
Again, I want to
stress, for free.
It's relatively cheap and easy.
I haven't talked yet about
10 billion tweets, which
I've got, which I
can map to US county
and look at variations
in personality,
in inequality, in racism
across county level
piece or communities.
It's a way to get at what
people are thinking and feeling
as they talk to
their friends or post
to their blogs or the
discussion boards.
I want to end by noting
that what we've done here
is very basic-- male or female.
We're now looking
at gender spectrum.
People aren't either talking
male or talking female.
Everyone sits somewhere
on a spectrum,
and maybe it's even
two dimensions--
there's a degree of maleness
and a degree of femaleness
to people's language,
which is something
we can explore when we have
these really large data sets.
We can try to
understand-- eventually,
I hope-- across very different
subgroups of self-definition--
how their language varies.
I think this would be a
great time going forward
to get a picture in the
very large scale of what
life looks like within
people's very small worlds.
And that I thank you.
Thanks, that was a
really rich talk,
and we'll look forward
to some questions.
But first we have
Alice Marwick, who
is a social media researcher
based in New York City.
She's the Director
of the McGannon
Center for
Communication Research
and an assistant professor at
Fordham University's Department
of Communication
and Media Studies.
Her first book Status
Update-- Celebrity, Publicity,
and Branding in the
Social Media Age
came out with Yale a
couple of years ago,
and is a really
fascinating ethnography
of how people in the
San Francisco tech scene
use social media to boost
their status and popularity,
and how this affects
their offline lives.
And her current
research has moved more
towards the proliferation of
sexism and misogynistic speech
online using such
topics as Gamergate
and the Donglegate
Reddit controversies
and online harassment as
places where she's looking.
So I look forward to this.
-Thank you.
It's great to be here.
It's wonderful to be at such
an interdisciplinary event.
I think that when we're tackling
these large, weighty topics
like language and gender,
it's great to see people
from across the spectrum
addressing them.
I'm an ethnographer,
and so I deal
in what we might call
small data-- interviews
and observations
which often can help
us to contextualize
and problematize
the findings of big data.
For the last 3 years,
I've been thinking
a lot about online
sexism, and today I'm
going to give a short
overview of the visibility
of online sexism, particularly
with regard to language,
and discuss the implications.
Social media like Twitter,
Reddit, and forums
enable collective action
and participation,
but they also enable a
new type of organized
gamified harassment
that works to shut down
the voices of women,
queer people, and people
of color online.
And I would like to give a
little bit of a trigger warning
that there is some very sexist
speech in this presentation,
and I think it's
important to present it
so you can see the magnitude of
what we're dealing with online.
So Zoe Quinn is a software
developer who became the target
of an organized brigade
after her ex-boyfriend wrote
a 10,000-word screed
about her on his blog.
He claimed that she
had lied to him,
that she cheated on
him with five guys,
and most damagingly
he claimed that Quinn
had slept with a writer for
Kotaku, a video game blog,
to get favorable coverage for
her game Depression Quest.
This was unequivocally
proven to be false,
but under the pretense that they
were trying to reform ethics
in video game journalism, a
group of gamers organizing
through websites and
chat rooms inundated
Ms. Quinn with thousands
of hateful messages.
They distributed
nude photos of her,
and her address and social
security number were revealed,
and this is a process
called doxing, where
people's personal
information is revealed
online for the purpose
of shaming and harassing.
People called her parents,
they called her phone
at all hours of the
night, they openly
discussed raping
her, her weight,
and the smell of her vagina.
This brigade unified around
the Twitter hashtag Gamergate.
As the harassment
escalated, Anita Sarkeesian,
a feminist media critic
and favorite target
of anti-feminist gamers
for several years,
was also doxed and
forced to cancel
an appearance at the University
of Utah due to a death threat.
Another game
developer, Briana Wu,
posted anti-Gamergate
memes on Tumblr and Twitter
and also received death threats.
And actress Felicia Day, a
longtime gaming advocate,
wrote an emotional blog
post about the effects
that Gamergate was having on her
ability to trust male gamers,
and she was promptly
doxed for her trouble.
But Gamergate is only
the latest kerfuffle
in a series of well-documented
and often high-profile
incidents in which
women have been openly
harassed, stalked, or otherwise
systemically targeted online
for political and
feminist speech,
for criticizing the video game
or technology industry, or just
for existing.
These high-profile cases
are the most extreme
of a general atmosphere
of sexist speech,
gendered harassment, and
misogynistic comments
in many places online.
Moreover, and what I think is
most interesting about this,
is that these brigades
are organized.
Sarkeesian refers to these
groups as cyber mobs.
They're collectives which engage
in cooperative competition
to increase the harm
to their victims.
They reinforce their
social dominance
over marginalized groups.
And what this means
is that people
use social media
to work together
to learn personal information
about their targets.
They gain status
in their community
as they escalate the harassment.
And in this way, online
harassment becomes a game.
Those of us who have ever
read YouTube comments
or waded into forums like 4chan
or even some parts of Reddit
have seen sexist
terms, jokes like women
should be in the kitchen or make
me a sandwich, or men simply
calling women fat,
ugly, and slutty--
the triumvirate of uncreative
but expected gendered insults.
Now, of course, this is
not restricted to sexism.
The comment sections
of blogs and websites
are often rife with
racist, sexist, homophobic,
transphobic, and just plain
mean and profane language.
The harassment of women
of color and queer women
is often compounded
by intersectionality.
When I appeared on television
to talk about online sexism,
the channel posted
the video on YouTube
and the comments on the
channel were terrible.
So I posted my favorite
comment-- I respect women
but I hate feminists.
I believe that feminists
should be gang raped.
And Helen Lewis, a
British journalist,
posted what she
calls Lewis's law--
the comments on any
article about feminism
justify feminism.
And unfortunately,
Lewis's law has
proven to be very much
true in my own experience.
Women in certain online
spaces frequently
find themselves the
subject of attacks
that use sexual violence
and gendered speech
acts as intimidation.
I have heard about this from
political writers, economists,
feminist bloggers,
technologists,
music writers, and journalists.
One friend moved her
family to a different city
after she was stalked based
on her feminist writing.
The blog Feministing had
a dedicated FBI agent
to deal with death threats,
and a science blogger I know
has been stalked for 9 years
by someone who follows her
on every social media platform.
And as Laurie Penny, a financial
writer for The Independent,
wrote, "An opinion, it
seems, is the short skirt
of the internet.
Having one and
flaunting it is somehow
asking an amorphous mass of
almost entirely male keyboard
bashers to tell you how
they'd like to rape,
kill, and urinate on you."
So you might ask,
don't both genders
deal with harassment
and meanness online?
And yes, this is
definitely true.
And as you can see in this
graph from the Pew Research
Center, which is a
nonprofit that researches
online behavior,
both men and women
experience online harassment,
meanness, and cruelty.
But two interesting
things-- first of all,
you can see that the rates are
much higher for younger people,
and this only looks
at people 18 and over,
and so the youngest
groups of people
are the ones who are
experiencing the most
harassment.
And if we had numbers
for 13- to 18-year-olds,
we might also see that
they're experiencing
large amounts of harassment.
And the other thing
I think that's
interesting about
this graph is if you
look at the number of men versus
women who are being stalked
or sexually harassed or that
the harassment is sustained,
it's greater for
women than for men.
But besides harassment,
the normalization
of misogynistic
language online is
something that
I'm also following
and that I'm concerned about.
And scholars have pointed to
the emergence of a Manosphere
as a central contributor to
the spread of online sexism.
And the Manosphere-- this is
the men's rights Subreddit.
So Reddit is a
discussion forum and it
has a lot of subsections,
and each Subreddit
is dedicated to a
different topic,
and this one is dedicated
to men's rights.
And the Manosphere consists
of websites and message boards
where men discuss
men's rights, pick up
artist techniques,
the feminist agenda,
and in more extreme cases,
bond over misogynistic ideals.
And the Southern
Poverty Law Center
characterizes the
Manosphere as "an underworld
of so-called men's rights groups
and individuals on the internet
which is just
fraught with really
hardline, anti-women misogyny."
Now, the Manosphere, to a
certain extent, is diverse.
It's spread across different
websites and technologies
from mainstream sites like
Reddit and Hacker News
to more obscure corners
of the internet.
But these separate
subcultures are
homophilous In other words,
birds of a feather flock
together.
When people with
similar views spend
most of their time
interacting with other people
with the same views,
a polarizing effect
happens in that their views
tend to become more extreme.
Thus the development of these
male-centric communities
may encourage sexist speech
and allow men to work together
to systematically devalue
women's contributions
or even harass women.
And I want to make a
note on demographics.
The title of this talk
No Girls on the Internet
refers to a maxim that's thrown
around on male-centric sites
like Reddit or in gamer
groups-- oh, there's
no women on the internet.
Every woman you meet on
the internet is just a guy
pretending to be a woman.
But actually we see in the
United States that about 86%
of both men and women
are on the internet.
There's a gap in access in
terms of class and education,
but there is not one
in terms of gender.
But we also know that most
social media users are women.
About 60% of Facebook
users are women.
Most Twitter users are women.
The same with Flickr, Tumblr,
Instagram, and Pinterest.
On the other hand,
LinkedIn, 4chan, and Reddit
are primarily used by men.
Now, there may be a
participation gap.
87% of Wikipedia
contributors are male.
Male students are more
likely than female students
to create, edit, and
distribute digital video
over YouTube or Facebook.
But this doesn't hold
true for content creation
over Tumblr or Instagram.
So if there are plenty of girls
and women on the internet,
but they may not be hanging
out in the same spaces as men,
this homophily may be
compounded by a relative absence
of female contributions
in some spaces.
And this combines
with what we really
see as an emerging troll
culture on spaces like 4chan
in which extreme racist, sexist,
homophobic, and ablest insults
are used to insult
people, to shock them,
and to produce a certain
type of affect in the people
that these insults are aimed at.
Now, what this means is that
egregiously sexist slurs online
are becoming normalized,
and this is especially
true for young people.
This is a graphic
that I have love.
MRA stands for men's
rights activists,
and surrounded by misandry.
And much of the
Manosphere's supporters
are speaking about
sexism and gender
extensively, but in
a bizarre world way.
Now, don't get me wrong.
I think that the patriarchy
hurts men just as much
as it does women,
and I think that men
should talk about
masculinity and changes
in masculinity and
things like that.
But that's not what's
going on in these spaces.
Let me give you an example
from another Subreddit, which
is called The Red Pill, which
is a pick up artist community.
And The Red Pill
summarizes itself
as "discussion of sexual
strategy in a culture
increasingly lacking a
positive identity for men."
And it refers to the
moment in the sci-fi movie
The Matrix where the
protagonist, Neo, takes
the red pill and has his eyes
opened to the dystopian reality
of his world-- what
1970s feminists would
call consciousness-raising,
and what people today say
means to be a "woke" person.
To Red Pillers, the red
pill reveals the reality
of a world where the deck
is stacked against men
and feminized
behavior is rewarded.
And I could spend the rest
of this lecture just talking
about The Red Pill, but let
me give you an example of one
of their theories.
Women are very
emotional, and most women
make their decisions based
on their emotional state
at the time.
The rationalization
hamster is an analogy
for the thought processes used
by women to turn bad behavior
and bad decisions
into acceptable ones
to herself and her friends.
When a woman makes
a bad decision,
the hamster spins in its
wheel-- the woman's thinking--
and creates some type
of acceptable reason
for that bad decision.
The crazier decision,
the faster the hamster
must spin in order to
successfully rationalize away
the insanity.
So that's the type
of deep thinking
about gender and sexism that
is going on in these spaces.
Now, Subreddits
like The Red Pill
and groups like men's
rights activists
do not agree on
everything, but they
do share a common language.
They have been highly
successful in popularizing
their own vocabulary including
terms like misandry--
their word for feminism, the
male equivalent of misogyny--
defined as dislike for, contempt
for, or ingrained prejudice
against men, white
knighting, which
is men who espouse feminist
views or speak up for women,
and the idea is that
they're doing so in order
to appear heroic
and appeal to women,
and social justice
warriors, which
is a pejorative
term for anyone who
engages in feminist, anti-racist
or pro-queer activism
or discourse.
And they often co-opt activist
and social justice rhetoric.
So not only do we have an
increase in sexist slurs,
we have an increase in
these rhetorical moves
to discuss feminism using
intrinsically anti-feminist
words like misandry.
And you'll see this
throughout the internet
in a wide variety of
spaces, from Twitter
to comments on tech blogs,
to places like Facebook.
And this graph is
from Google Analytics
and it shows how
misandry basically
came out of nowhere before
2007 and has gradually
increased in popularity in
terms of people Googling for it,
talking about it, and
speaking about it.
So I want to talk about
a couple of implications
in my last few minutes.
First, I want to
think about the idea
that internet culture encourages
participation and creativity.
Websites like 4chan or
the men's rights Subreddit
are generative communities
of online participation
and activism.
In many ways they are what we
might call social movements
or communities of practice.
They often resemble
organized fandom
in their desire to learn
everything about and obsess
over their targets, but they
are anti-fans in that they hate
and despise their subjects.
And I think we need
to stop categorizing
creative participation as, by
definition, a positive thing.
The second implication is the
chilling effects of harassment.
Kathy Sierra, a prominent tech
blogger who wrote about user
experience-- hardly a
controversial topic--
was so badly harassed
that she stopped blogging
and stepped away from
her former career
as a public speaker and
visible tech expert.
She was discouraged
from earning a living
due to online harassment.
Now, this is very
understandable given
how scary and problematic
harassment can be,
but it also compounds
the problem.
If women stop voicing opinions
in traditionally male realms
like economics, politics, and
technology, the women who do so
will continue to be
seen as outliers.
But I think that
what is more likely
is that rather than
stopping participating,
women will move to the
more female friendly parts
of the internet.
Now, there's nothing wrong
with fashion blogging,
mommy blogging, or
Pinterest, but they
tend to focus on very
traditional views of women
and have a somewhat conservative
norm of femininity--
looking pretty,
being a great cook,
or making your own baby food.
I interviewed fashion
bloggers during my postdoc
and what they all said
to me is that the norms
of their community was that
you must be nice online,
that you couldn't openly
criticize other people.
So this means that the safe
corners of the internet
may box women into
expressing themselves
through very traditional, almost
stereotypically feminine ways.
And as we all know,
women have plenty
to offer the world that is
not about fashion, cooking,
parenting, or homemaking.
It should not be the case that
the only way women can reliably
avoid online harassment is to
adhere to stereotypical gender
roles.
But I worry that that's where
these instances are heading.
So let's think about solutions.
Gendered harassment
and online sexism
is a very complicated problem.
It goes far beyond Gamergate
or even the technology industry
itself.
But unfortunately
there is as of yet
no good legal or
policy solution.
Internet harassment is
difficult to come about
through legal means.
There are issues of jurisdiction
and most importantly free
speech.
The police are
often unsympathetic
or do not understand
the technical issues.
They often tell victims to
simply stay off the internet.
Moderation is very expensive.
Companies like
Twitter are finally
beginning to build tools
in to combat harassment,
but they have been slow to
adopt proactive solutions.
And I will say that
as companies build
in things like being
able to flag posts
or being able to turn people
in for various violations,
those are frequently
used against women,
against feminists, against queer
people as a form of harassment
by these sort of brigades.
Every day new online
communities and apps
are launched with
the assumptions
that their users will be good
actors, without any protection
for those who may be harassed.
Online sexism, however,
is not something
that we merely have to tolerate.
There are already many
women organizing themselves
to combat it on blogs,
Tumblr, Twitter, and Reddit,
whether by technical
means or support networks.
If you are the victim of
harassment or sexist speech,
I urge you to seek out social
support from other people going
through similar things.
And I also urge
everyone in this room
to speak out against
sexist language
when you see it online with
the goal of, if not eliminating
online harassment
and sexism, making
it less common, acceptable,
and part of the every day.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
That's an excellent
contribution.
And now we're going to
have about 15 or 20 minutes
of discussion among
the panel, and maybe we
can talk about the differences
in their approaches and aims
for their research.
And then we'll have
time for some questions
from the audience, and
we'll set up a mic shortly.
So I was really struck
by some commonalities
among these presentations
in the sense
that there's a kind of
overwhelming feeling
that a lot of data produced
from the online world,
from the sources that
you've all worked with,
tends to retrench or reinforce
preexisting stereotypes
and norms, despite the rhetoric
we often hear about disruption,
revolution, new forms arising.
And so I wonder if you could
each comment on that paradox.
-I think it goes
both directions.
So on the one hand,
there is this huge weight
of reinforcement
of common things
because people form
these homophilic groups
and do things.
Other hand, we haven't
talked about social change.
And one thing we've
been looking at
is tracking, for
example, changes
in domestic partner violence
discussion which has changed.
The names behind it have changed
many times in the last decade.
You can see the use
of mainstream events
that are reported in the
mainstream media being
picked up by social media
and in turn driving policy.
You can see this tremendous
groundswell of organizing.
So I think that on the one hand,
there's this reinforcement.
On the other, hand,
it is a great medium
for social activism,
and you can actually
see public policy starting
to be affected more
at the local level.
It's harder at the national
level to have this effect,
but I live in Philadelphia,
reasonably big city,
and it's still the
case that organizers
can get enough of a groundswell
to influence public policy.
-So perhaps there's
some backlash,
but also evidence of--
-Also organizing and
people mobilizing.
-I think that it depends
which way you cut the data.
Comparing your
assessment of how women
tend to talk online compared
with men on Facebook.
Interestingly, we
ran something--
it's very, very unusual
for a client of ours
to ask for a gender split.
That almost never happens,
which is a good thing.
They're more interested in the
persona in general of people.
But we were asked to compare
self-validated Twitter--
successful people on Twitter.
So this is normally people
who in their bio on Twitter
describe themselves
as successful,
and then split it male female.
And women talk about
politics and issues
more than men in that group.
And on the whole, actually,
women use more pronouns,
they're more conversational,
and so on and so on.
So on the whole,
I think, men still
kind of resort to
numbers, and sport,
and all this kind of stuff.
That's generally true.
But I think when you split away
from just the straight male
female split and you split and
compare things in other ways,
then I think other truths
revealed themselves.
-One of the things I
think is most interesting
about social media
is that it's used
by a very wide,
diverse group of people
with a lot of
different opinions.
And often this means
that conversations
that have been going on for
years among different groups
and communities get bubbled
up and other people can
see those who aren't
necessarily part
or don't understand the
context of this conversation.
I think this speaks
to what Janet Mock was
saying in her keynote about
the title of her memoir.
What we see on
Twitter especially
is that often there'll
be a group like, say,
young African Americans
talking about something
with a particular
hashtag, and then that
becomes visible to other
groups who don't necessarily
understand the context of that.
And then you can get this harsh,
quick backlash against it.
Like, you'll see people making
a bunch of racist comments
because a conversation is
visible to them that has always
gone on, but they have
not been able to see it
until social media
has made that visible.
And so I think that
when we're looking
at how social media both
contributes to reinforcing
and resisting these
norms, I think
we can see that a lot social
activism, as Lyle said,
has gone on through
social media.
You just have to look at
the black lives matter
hashtag, you have to look
at the contemporary moment
in popular culture around
feminism, which is something
that for, like, a
decade there was
lots of feminist stuff going
on, but it really hadn't made it
into the mainstream.
And it's a pop
culture, and I think
a lot of that has been due to
the work of young feminists
on different platforms,
doing that work,
and then that work being
able to disseminate
into the mainstream, as well.
So for all of my terrifying
rhetoric in my talk about how
terrible these
clashes are, I think
that there's something
quite empowering,
especially for
young people, to be
able to have these conversations
and have them impact
the mainstream in a way that
wasn't possible before they had
access to social
media technologies
and other ways of broadcasting
their thoughts to a larger
audience.
-Yeah, I think what
strikes me is that there's
a kind of dynamic of this rapid
emergence of proliferation
of voices.
I love the comment
in our keynote,
we can now broadcast
our lives, and this idea
of multi-layering, the idea of
the proliferation of genders
and even the way
they're obviously
reflected in Facebook.
But at the same time there's a
kind of retrenchment and fear
that gets triggered by
these kinds of things,
and so you see other
forces arising.
And so this reinforces,
I guess, the idea
that this is a very
rich area for research.
And I wondered
what you all think
are the advantages
and disadvantages
of the methods you've chosen?
I mean, Lyle and
Ben work largely
with quantitative methods
and Alice with qualitative,
and I wondered if you could
comment on the advantages
and disadvantages of each.
-We do actually both
qualitative and quantitative.
I think the key thing is the
amount of data you can collect.
I don't care about
the number, but just
get a flavor of
different subgroups--
what are they
talking about when?
What language are they using?
What do they care about?
To go out and run
interviews-- really expensive.
To do telephone calls,
surveys-- Gallup
recently finished
their millionth survey.
I have 10 billion tweets.
I can't afford the
budget of Gallup,
but I can run more
questionnaires than they can.
I can look at changes at a finer
spatial and temporal resolution
than they can.
The world is changing from
a research standpoint--
be able to pinpoint look at
what's happening in Cambridge
versus Boston over this debate.
And I think this
level of exposure
is, in fact,
tremendously powerful.
-Yeah, I think we
have a similar view
in that until
comparatively recently,
you had the choice
between quant-- that
is, number-driven stuff.
But in language on the
internet, that basically
gave you something like
sentiment analysis,
so is it 34% positive?
A, it's not particularly
accurate, and B,
even if it was really accurate,
what does that even mean?
The other way is with qual,
you get a lot of nuance,
a lot of complex
answers and drilling in,
but of course, you get to ask
20 people in a focus group who
never tell you the truth anyway
because you're asking them
the question so you
bias the answer.
So we are getting
to the point now
where you can get qual-type
insights at quant scale.
From our perspective,
doing comparisons
is always the key thing.
The hard bit is always what
comparisons do you want to run?
Because there's
so much to compare
and so much to draw
out, it's almost
too powerful a technique.
-As somebody who
mostly does, as I
said, small data work in
that I interview people,
I often spend large amounts
of time in the communities
that I'm studying, I spend a
lot of time talking to people
and trying to
understand how they
make a meaning of their
world and their lives,
I think one of the most
important issues in data
analysis right now
is that of ethics.
Just because you can collect
and look at something
doesn't mean that you should
collect and look at it.
And a lot of colleagues--
well, not a lot.
There's been several
cases in my field
in which, say somebody was doing
an ethnography of, like, Tumblr
feminists or something,
and one of the research
subjects posts a
Tumblr post saying,
researchers are
not welcome here,
I don't want you looking at
my stuff, this is not for you,
this is not your space.
And we see lots of
indicators by which people
are trying to target
their online communication
to a particular audience.
They're using particular
linguistic codes,
they're marking their
speech in some way,
saying it's for a
particular peer group.
And I have another
whole research area
on online privacy, which is
one of my other main research
areas, and what we see
is that people often--
even if they know that
someone can see something
that they post on Facebook
or Twitter or whatnot,
they assume that
people will know
what audience it's for based
on the language that they use.
And the problem with big
data research methods
is that that's all lost.
It all gets scooped
up and analyzed
and there's no IRB,
Institutional Review Board,
review usually needed
for big data whereas--
-No, everything we do is IRB.
-Oh, everything is IRB?
-I have a full-time
person doing IRBs.
Every person who shares their
Facebook consents both to me,
something approved by IRB--
-No, your work-- 100%.
You said you have seven--
-Everthing is IRB.
I can't say how much
time I spend making sure
that everybody signs off.
-All right, I'm sorry.
I was not meaning
to single the two
gentlemen to the right of me.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
-I know I sound defensive,
but it's important.
-There's a lot of conferences
where people are presenting
work that is not as rigorous
as Lyle's in terms of the data
collection they--
-And most companies
don't have IRBs--
don't have IRB.
---is a much worse problem.
-And one of the things that
we see that's also problematic
is that companies like Facebook
have enormous internal research
departments and
they don't publish
a lot of their research, and we
don't know what they're doing,
and we don't know what
kind of experiments
they're doing on Facebook users.
So first of all,
academics in general
are at a disadvantage when
it comes to big social media
organizations.
And second of all,
there is this sense
that there are
bodies of researchers
who aren't doing that kind of
ethical work that I'm doing,
that Lyle is doing, that other
researchers around the country
are doing.
So I think these
are some of just
the general ethical
questions that are brought up
in the age of big
data, and I think
we're going to be
working those out
in our various subfields
for years to come.
They're very hot
topics right now.
-Just from my
experience teaching
this class on big data, a
couple of the greatest areas
of the growth of
the use of big data
are in predictive policing,
so use by police forces
to target certain
areas where crimes
may occur based on
patterns and data,
and then send more police
there or patrol differently
or interview people they
believe at the age of 17
may commit a crime
when they're 19
or things like that that used
to be reserved for dystopian
fiction are actually programs
in at least five cities already
underway.
And also as Alice
indicated, there's
quite an unregulated
use of data.
When you sign your user
agreement with Facebook,
I believe you agree
to basically to become
an experimental subject.
And it's interesting when you
look at the Facebook experiment
that came out about 2 years
ago, which was published
in a high-impact
journal, that this caused
a huge uproar,
that it turned out
this was quite a simple
experiment where it was shown
that with something
like 33 million-- many,
many users, if you
change their feed,
the news feed, if you move it
towards more positive stories,
people would then start to
make more positive comments
in their feed.
And there was also
a negative result
so you could apparently
emotionally engineer
the Facebook audience.
And this caused an outcry.
But in fact, these
type of small changes
are being tested all the time.
It was more the fact
that it became public.
So there's actually an
increasing divide, perhaps,
between the academic world
and the commercial world,
or perhaps between data-driven
science and big data.
So these are all areas
that are a lot going on,
I guess we could say.
One theme that I thought was
interesting that came out
in all of your
presentations was--
or I would be interested in
hearing your comments on this--
was that there were
changes among younger users
or in the data that you got
from younger people, or else
as Alice said, that younger
people seem to experience
greater levels of harassment.
And I would imagine
that maybe also--
or maybe you could
comment on this--
was the language that younger
people using showing up
as different?
-Yes, I didn't show it.
We can tell within 5
years someone's age
from their Facebook language
extremely straightforward.
Some of them are use
of things like pronouns
or "the," which old people
say "the," putting spaces
after periods, but down
to fine-grain versions.
People keep talking about "lol"
here with the [INAUDIBLE],
but in fact the current "lol"
is mostly League of Legends.
You old people are still
laughing out loud from, like,
the '90s, was that?
So there's huge
changes happening,
and several people
have alluded to it,
but there's lots of
in-group signaling.
And it really is the case
that you ship people.
It's a verb, not a noun.
These things have
shifted massively
in the last couple of years,
and you can see them stratified.
The 14-year-olds
and the 16-year-olds
look really different.
Also, they're shifting
in terms of moving away
from old, slow platforms like
Twitter to Snapchat, Instagram,
much more communication with
images with small amounts
of text attached.
You old people still type words.
That's very retro.
I'm in favor of it, I'm a
word guy, I use words, too.
But the whole notion
of how communication
occurs-- visual,
streaming, instant.
If you missed it, you'll get
something else the next hour.
Why are you going to store
at look at yesterday's email?
That's so antique.
So I think the style
of communication
is changing even more
than the content,
and I think it's something
to look at-- the notion
of how does communication occur?
How does bonding occur?
I'm old enough to
remember people
talking on telephones
to each other, very
quaint, slow
communication, not texting
in the middle of the conference
to see what you just saw.
-Yeah, so maybe just
comments from Ben and Alice
and then we'll have
some questions.
-I actually had to explain
to my 9-year-old son
last week why it's called "YLS".
By the way, David
Cameron thought
it was "lots of love," as
well, our Prime Minister.
That shows how in touch the
UK is with the modern times.
I don't know about platforms,
but we've certainly
seen significant differences
between the way younger age
groups discuss a given
topic compared with olders.
And there's a unifying theme.
So we did this for a
handset manufacturer,
and if you look at the reviews
of mobile phone handsets
by age group, the younger
you are the more expressive
you tend to be, so it's
beautiful, gorgeous, awesome,
sleek-- that kind of stuff.
Younger people talk a lot more
about the quality of the camera
being important, they talk a
lot more about the battery life
being important.
But my favorite, I think,
is overuse of the word
"definitely" because
you only know everything
when you're young.
And your opinions are far more
polarized the younger you are.
And so it's beautiful,
gorgeous, fantastic,
and I definitely recommend it.
And I won't go into what
old people talk about.
That's too embarrassing.
But definitely big differences.
-I want to echo Lyle's comments
about platforms like Snapchat.
And one of the projects
I'm working on right now is
on privacy and
socioeconomic status,
and we're interviewing
16-to-26-year-olds.
And one of the things that
I find so interesting about
the 16-, 17-, 18-year-olds is
that within every high school
there are often apps
that-- well, first of all,
apps and mobile devices,
they're very trendy,
so the kids will all use an app
for a specific amount of time
and then they'll move
on to another app.
And often that is very localized
within a group of friends
or a high school, and kids will
share the same media ideologies
around a particular
communication platform
and then they'll move
on to something else
usually once their parents
discover that it exists.
So it's not even
solely generational.
Communication is extraordinarily
contextual in every single way.
It differs by age, by
community, by class position,
by access-- whether
you're mostly
accessing the
internet on your phone
or whether you have
access to a laptop or not.
All of these things
are quite different.
And so this is one
of the nice things,
again, about qualitative work
is that you can drill down
into these very particular
ways, and rather
than trying to make
generalizations,
you can really understand how
communication technologies
affect young people's sense
of identity expression
and their relationships
with other people.
And what we find
is these effects
are often quite profound.
-Thank you.
So we'd love to take some
questions from the audience.
-Hi, my name is Ashley.
I am a graduate
student in psychology,
and I just want to
put the disclaimer
that I am heavily entrenched
in qualitative research,
so that's a big bias.
I'm currently
involved in a study.
We use personal narratives
of HIV-positive women,
ethnic minority.
And if one were to
look at their language
among these
100-something narratives,
it would look really similar.
They're all from pretty much
the same socioeconomic status
right outside of Chicago,
around the same age.
But what we find is when we
look at these narratives,
there are just vast
amounts of nuance,
like you were speaking to,
and we've used this data--
it's longitudinal, so
we've used a lot of this
to look at coping styles
in women and viral loads.
And it has affected
policy change
on a really effective level.
And that's a little
bit of a tangent,
but I guess I just see
this really big danger
and clumping this
together in almost
like an essentialist
notion, and I
see some possibility of
it moving social justice
movements backwards.
And this may be a knee-jerk
reaction to seeing women being
associated with using the
word "shopping" so much,
but when you're just
looking at their language,
you're not getting
their backstory,
the demographics,
you're not getting
the nuance, it
would be easy to come up with
essentialist notions of what
this is looking like.
So I guess I'm
just wondering how
do you keep it from
moving us backwards
in the feminist movement,
the queer movement, so on?
-I think the big data does offer
a huge benefit, which I did not
talk about today, in actually
splitting rather than lumping.
So it is the case I look
at our 20-something year
old, poor, African American--
they use Twitter really
different than 50-year-old
white men or women who
are more professional,
or blacks of that age.
There's huge differences.
The thing is we
can actually look
at detailed narratives of
people from Camden, New
Jersey, different
parts of Philadelphia.
We do collect,
actually, narratives.
People volunteer and write
essays and share them with us.
So I think it really is
important to contextualize,
and I apologize if
I over-simplified.
Really different to look
at work discussions,
family discussions,
peer discussions.
So I think different platforms--
all these things can be done.
It's really easy to just
average, and what do you get?
You get straight,
you get middle-aged
because that's the average,
you get white because that's
the majority.
So sure, if you
don't split stuff,
then you obscure
all the variation.
The nice thing, certainly
if you're a Facebook or
of that size, you can
split it is finely
as you want and look at the
really micro-communities
and the variations.
You can get the backstory.
We're now taking
people and getting
them to share their
entire medical history
and their full Facebook history.
We know their age, their sex,
we know what sort of insurance
they have.
We know a lot about
these people--
again, with their
informed consent.
And you can go back.
So I think it's a
real danger that it's
easy to be facile and say, oh
yeah, girls say "shopping."
That's nice but that's
not true of all girls,
and not all of them are girls.
-I'm thinking of a couple of
examples where-- much of this
is about how you apply and
think through what you're trying
to communicate and who you're
trying to communicate it to,
and where the potential
for miscommunication lies.
So there's a medical example
where we've done work
with some pharmaceutical
companies,
and if you think about the
journey from the pharma company
to the patient getting
a benefit, the way
the pharma company
talks about a condition
compared with how doctors
talk about the same condition
compared with how patients talk
about the same condition subtly
shifts to the point where this
word that the patient uses--
they're meaning the same
thing as the pharma company,
but it all gets
lost in translation.
And we've had some reasonably
interesting and successful
results where
somebody has modified
their style of communication
for the person they're
trying to target, and it's
had very positive results.
-I just want to add to
that the on social media,
a lot of the
language that we see
is quite performative in that
people are often attempting
to manage the impression that
they're making on other people.
So they're using affiliative
language practices in order
to either-- the
woman who constantly
is talking about cute
dogs and shopping--
I mean, I talk about cute
dogs on Twitter-- quite a bit,
I might add.
But she might also be
trying to affiliate herself
in certain ways or
trying to perform
a particular type of fem
identity for a particular end.
And I think that
when we're thinking
about the visible identity
cues that people are making
on social media, we also
have to think about the fact
that many people see social
media as somewhere where
they have a particular persona
that they're furthering.
And one of the other things
that I'm interested in
is how a lot of the time
those personas get branded,
that people start
thinking of themselves
as using advertising and
marketing strategies in using
social media and
reaching out to others,
and I think that that's
the kind of thing
that the qualitative
work that you're doing,
that Lyle is talking
about, that can really
add to our understanding of
those types of social media
linguistic practices.
-Thank you.
-Hello, my name is Kiera.
I'm from Connecticut College.
I'm a sophomore there.
And I'm curious-- this
question's for Alice--
what's your opinion on Yik Yak?
-Oh, so those of you who don't
know, Yik Yak is a mobile app.
It is sort of like
anonymous Twitter,
that you can say things
anonymously and it can get up
or down voted by the
rest of your community.
And it's geolocated, meaning
that generally you're
seeing Yik Yaks from
people around you.
So I work at Fordham
University, I often
look at the Fordham Yik Yak.
And also it's been accused of
being used for bullying a lot,
so Yik Yak has tried to put
all these really interesting
technical affordances
to police user behavior,
like you're not supposed to
mention other people by name,
and they geofence
off the boundary.
So my apartment is close
to a secondary school,
so I can't use Yik Yak
within my apartment
because it thinks I'm
a high school student.
All right, whatever.
I think anonymous internet
communication is interesting.
I think that it affords
some very positive things.
Quite frequently
there is evidence
that people find it easier
to share with other people
when they're not having
their information tied back
to a singular identity, tied
to their marketing profile.
And I think it is
important for people
to have places to
express things that they
can't express in other places.
On the other hand,
I think it's also
a place where people
can express things
that are very offensive
or problematic
or might really
hurt somebody else.
And the thing about Yik Yak is
they'll give personal data over
to law enforcement without
even thinking about it.
That's one of their things.
If you, say, Yik Yak, oh,
I want to bomb the school,
they'll give that over
to the cops and the cops
will arrest that person and
that's happened several times.
So I go back and forth.
I don't believe that
technology is neutral at all.
I believe that technology
can and does express
its own politics and values.
And the people
behind Yik Yak seemed
like their ideal was to create
something for self-expression.
I don't know, what's
your opinion of Yik Yak?
I would be curious.
-I don't have Yik Yak.
-You don't have Yik Yak?
-I deleted it a while ago.
-Does it have influence
on your campus?
-Yes, but I try not to see it.
-Yeah.
But I do know that
there's been a lot
of other similar, anonymous,
campus-based things
in the past.
There used to be something
called JuicyCampus,
which was a gossip.
People like to gossip.
College students love to gossip.
that People are going to use
social media sites to gossip.
I'm not sure whether I would
say that the negative effects
of anonymity outweigh
the positive effects,
but I think it is
important for people
to have anonymous spaces online.
-As a researcher
I think it's also
important-- people are
always performative.
They're putting on a
persona on Facebook,
they're putting
on one right now.
As we talk to each other,
we're doing a persona.
And it's interesting
to me to be able to see
some of these people who are
often fairly nasty on Yik Yak,
but the chance to actually see
what they're seeing in a way
that they will not
show me as an authority
figure from the establishment
to know what's going on.
So I don't find much of the
discussion very pleasant,
but I guess I do like to know
what people are talking about.
And in the end
end, that, I think,
is an important
facet quite apart
from the separate question of is
it beneficial or harmful, which
is not so obvious.
-Since we have four more
questions let's move on.
-I'm writing a history of
the Equal Rights Amendment
in graphic novel form, which
ends up being really look
at the citizenship
of women and men
and the history of
it in this country.
And one of the things you
notice in the early on
is that there is a
very deliberate attempt
to create spheres--
the women will operate
in the domestic sphere
and the men will
operate in the public sphere.
And so it's interesting to
look at how men talk publicly
about politics and about
sports, and you often
find, of course, they
talk about them similarly,
that they're the teams.
And I've noticed
as someone who is
a woman who talks publicly about
politics, I get policed by men.
And I also get women who write
to me and say, oh my god,
thank you for saying
that publicly.
And then I get little
secret messages.
And I have lots of
little background forum
of women reassuring each other.
And a friend of mine, a man,
wrote a piece supporting
Hillary Clinton, which
went kind of viral,
and he said he got lots of
messages from women saying,
thank god I had this to share.
I was afraid to say I supported
Hillary Clinton because I
didn't want to get yelled at,
but I could share this and be
like, look, this guy likes her.
So it's funny to compare the
women talking about shopping
publicly and then the
harassment that women
get for talking publicly.
How much of that is about are
women talking in the background
that we don't know about?
How much of that is
affecting each other
and what they talk about?
-Does anyone want
to tackle that one?
-I think the different
platforms are very different,
so you're communicating with
your friends over Facebook
is very different from
publishing in a blog,
and very different from being
in a gaming community which
are notoriously competitive,
would be a polite way
to put it.
So I think that there are many,
many different communities
and each person participates
in them in different ways,
and it's very hard to
generalize across them.
-One of the things that
we found in our research
with young people is that
young people will often
use a multiplexity of
different apps to communicate,
and they'll often
have one of those apps
will act as a sort of safety
valve, which is where they feel
that they can be more honest.
And quite often that's
because either they're
using a pseudonym on
a site like Tumblr,
or they're communicating with
a smaller group of people,
like they have a group text
on WhatsApp or something
and that's where they share
their more intimate feelings.
But thing about
that is then you're
not participating
in what we would
think of as the "public sphere.
And what we see historically
in the history of the internet
is that men's speeches tended
to be more in the public sphere.
That the blogs
written by men were
valued more than the online
journals written by women,
and when people are
talking about who's
participating in the
kind of online punditry
that we see on
sites like Medium,
oftentimes it's men who are
going into those spaces.
So I think that there
is certainly a value
placed on where people are
participating and talking
about things.
And I do think that
the fact that there
is this systematic
discouragement of women
speaking in these sort
of internet public
spheres-- I think that's a
very significant problem.
I really do.
I think it's a devaluing
of women's contributions
to the political sphere,
to the public sphere,
and frankly I think it's
a problem with democracy.
-So since we've got
two more questions,
I thought you could
ask them successively
and then we'll have
one or two comments.
-Hello, my name is
Caitlin Hannigan.
I'm a strategic
communication major
at Bridgewater State University,
my first senior year.
So Alice, I actually connected
with a lot of the stuff
that you were talking
about because we talk
a lot about that in my classes.
And my question's more
geared towards you,
but anyone is welcome to
answer if they have an opinion.
But I don't know if
you guys remember,
but last spring, Curt
Schilling tweeted something
out about his daughter
being accepted
into a college on a
scholarship for softball.
And immediately
responding, people
were sending her death
threats-- I'm going to rape her,
I'm going to do this,
we're going to find her,
all of that stuff.
So my question is pretty much
I know you've done research
on age and gender
and stuff, but I
don't know if there's a
difference with the celebrities
versus "normal people" I guess.
Not, like, normal people,
but you get what I'm saying.
Just because we talk
about that all the time,
but we talked earlier about
how we act differently
in front of different
audiences, and celebrities
do act differently
probably in the media
than they do at their homes
or with their families
or something.
So I was wondering about that.
-We'll come back to
that, and let's just
hear the last question.
-Hi, thanks.
My name is Orrin
[? Sur ?] and I'm
doing natural language
processing and big data.
And I want to go back to
Rebecca's famous quotation
of Anderson of big data
is the end of theory
and ask for your
respective takes on that.
-Schilling or end
of theory first?
Or does anyone want
to pick one of those?
-I'm happy to talk
about the Schilling.
So I think that,
first of all, we
have a culture of
criticizing celebrity women.
And many of us may not see
that as a very serious problem,
like, who cares if
Kim Kardashian gets
her feelings hurt?
But I think the problem is that
the distinction between who
is a celebrity and
who is not is changing
with the era of the internet.
So if everybody who puts
their pictures online
is now susceptible
to the same type
of severe, gendered criticism
that we put on famous women,
then it becomes an issue of
who is more public than others?
And if all of us are
making ourselves public,
and often we're forced
to make ourselves public
as a condition for young
people, for employment,
or for education, then we're all
susceptible to that same type
of deeply critical language.
And I think that's a problem.
The second thing is
I think that there
is a continuum of
celebrity practice
by which some people
are internet celebrities
or Facebook famous or
whatever, and they actively
are looking for
attention online.
That's what my first
book was all about,
was attention has a particular
type of social currency.
And so I think that when we're
talking about celebrities,
it's actually quite
important because celebrity
as a model of a
commodified self that
uses broadcast media
to publicize itself
is something that's
getting closer
to the intrinsic
subjectivity of social media
than we might like to think.
-Thanks.
Do you want to
tackle end of theory?
-Well, the limitation
of big data
is commercial people
to actually go and do
something interesting and
meaningful and useful with it.
I think that's the choke point.
-In speaking from the
standpoint of psychology,
it has for the last
50 years been largely
a theory-driven field, but
I see in the last few years
these big data are
pushing to be still mostly
theory, but increasingly
hypothesis-driven.
So the one thing that one
can do from these focus
groups of 10 million people
is go not with a theory,
but to say, hey, I
want to know what
people are saying about
transpeople or about cell
phones.
Let me not come
in with a theory.
Let me first observe empirically
what's being talked about,
and then tie that
back to underlying
theory of personality, or
whichever theory structure you
want.
So I think the ability
to generate hypotheses
is unbelievably powerful.
It's not just asking a
question to confirm or falsify
a hypothesis.
That's a very
different style, one
that's taken over
in medicine but is
fairly new to large parts
of the social sciences.
-Great.
So that's a good note to end
on, that data cannot speak
for itself.
And I want to thank
all these panelists
for presenting their research.